before we before we start so um
um
so you know as as you know uh
uh as you may have noticed um
you know this
this colloquium this semester has um has
developed a bit of a theme to it in in
the sense that it's uh many of the talks
have been aimed at getting
more of a dialogue between between
experiment and theory and so we're going
to be continuing that tradition today
actually in a in an even more intense
way um uh next week is thanksgiving so
there'll be no colloquium and then um
the week after that uh
robert huang from
caltech we'll talk about making
predictions in a quantum world so
that'll be our last colloquium for the
for this semester and then we'll resume
in january after that
okay so um so for today's uh talk um you
know as i said it's um
it's actually
um
you know
in this theme of of a dialogue between
between between theory and experiment
but in fact uh it's a dialogue between
theory and experiment within the same
talks so it's actually going to be
you know it's uh
really great to have andrew giorgio and
dave zoo here who are going to be tag
teaming today's
today's
colloquium so andrew will describe the
theoretical work and and and dive able
uh describe the experiment uh
that
they recently can uh conclude uh
concluded based on that work so let me
just uh introduce them um
alexandria giorgio he's a he's currently
a junior fellow at uh at eth zurich
um he got his phd from university of
edinburgh and then he did a postdoc at
caltech
he has done um
some very beautiful work on uh on
you know verification you know protocols
for verifying uh quantumness or quantum
clients with
classical verifies
um
davey zoo is
he just finished his phd at
university of maryland
um
working on uh trap tower and quantum
computers
and uh algorithms uh targeting near-term
quantum devices
um he is now a senior application
scientist at iron q
and um his research interests include
not just that but quantum algorithms um
hardware based quantum algorithm
optimization and the verification and
characterization of quantum devices so
looking forward to your talk so andrew
please
thank you so much
um so just to double check and everyone
or can someone at least hear me okay
yeah
okay
um
okay can you also see my cursor
when i move it on the screen looks good
andrew
okay thanks so much
so thank you so much mesh for the very
nice introduction it's a pleasure to be
speaking here
so as umesh said i'll be talking about
this work which was a very large
collaboration involving a number of
experimentalists as well as theorists
so i'm not going to name all of them you
can see them here and i just want to say
that
i'm grateful to all of them i think this
was you know a really nice collaboration
overall
okay so
we live in quite exciting times
from the perspective of someone working
on quantum computing
because just recently we've kind of seen
some of the first demonstrations of
what's known as quantum advantage so the
idea of performing a task efficiently on
a quantum device that we believe is
intractable for classical computers to
do
so the first such claim was from google
in 2019 and since then there have been
others from the university of science
and technology in china and just at a
kind of high level what
all of these experiments have generally
done is
to perform a random quantum circuit on a
device and then measure from the output
of that circuit and we have strong
theoretical evidence that this task is
hard to do for classical computers to
sample from that distribution
um but quantumly it's it's something
that we can do efficiently though i
don't want to say that it's easy because
it required a lot of technological
breakthroughs to get here
so um these demonstrations of quantum
advantage um
are you know they've been done with
existing devices which is really nice
and it really is due to this random
circuit sampling problem which uh kind
of lends itself to be implemented on the
devices that we currently have and as i
said there's also good theoretical
support for why this problem is
classically intractable
and also the
there's also some evidence that even if
you have noise in your system it's still
intractable to sample from that
distribution so even if you sample from
something close to that distribution
that should still be intractable
but there are also some um disadvantages
with this approach
and i would say the the main one in
relation to this work is that verifying
the results of your sampling task is
classically intractable
so the the problem is that you're not
directly verifying that you're sampling
from this distribution and so what you
do is you perform some sort of
statistical test on the samples that you
received
and the specific tests that were
performed are computing the linear
cross-entropy of these samples
and this is something that requires
exponential time to do classically so it
doesn't seem like this would scale up
and another more subtle problem
is that while we believe that sampling
from the distribution is hard
um we don't know whether that also
implies that spoofing this linear cross
entropy test is also hard
so there seems to be a gap there in
relating the hardness of of these two
things
so this kind of motivates and begs the
question is there some other way in
which we could do quantum advantage to
address these two issues
so this leads to the concept of
interactive proofs of quantumness um
which were introduced in this seminal
paper by rakerski christiano mahadev
azurani in vidiq in 2018
and
the general idea is
to have a protocol or a test an
interactive test between a classical
computer and a quantum computer or an
ostensibly quantum computer and the
point is that the quantum computer
should be able to pass the test but no
classical computer should be able to
assuming the hardness of some
cryptographic task
and i hope this will become clear
throughout the talk
so we have this classical computer which
i'll refer to as the verifier that is
trying to test this ostensibly quantum
computer to see if indeed it can pass
the tests in this protocol
and the general structure of such a
protocol is something where first you
have some sort of setup phase so an
initial message from the verifier to the
quantum computer that kind of sets up
the the cryptography that's used in the
protocol
um then the approver will perform
something that's called a commitment
step
and then there's a challenge that the
verifier issues relative to this
commitment and then it checks the
response of the quantum device from this
challenge
and what we'd like to achieve in this
protocol is if you're actually talking
to a quantum computer the verifier
should accept with very high probability
whereas if you're talking to just some
other classical computer then
she should reject with very high
probability
and
the inability of a classical party to
pass this test should be based on this
cryptographic assumption that kind of
underlies it so as i said uh these two
parties are the verifier and the prover
and from now on whenever i say efficient
i will mean that it can be done in
polynomial time
so there's a polynomial time algorithm
or like the number of rounds or sorry
the the amount of communication is
polynomial the number of operations is
polynomial in the size of some input
and also when i say intractable i mean
there's no polynomial time algorithm
and as i said this intractability will
come from some sort of cryptographic
assumption so let's see what um what
cryptography we would have to use to
design such a protocol
so in the
brackets at all result they relied on
this notion from cryptography called the
trapdoor claw free function so this is a
mathematical function that satisfies
four properties
first it should be efficient to evaluate
so given any input it's sufficient to
compute
an evaluation of the function
the function should be 2 to 1 meaning
that
for every point in the image of the
function for every evaluation of the
function there are exactly two inputs
that lead to that evaluation so two
pre-images we would call them
then this is where the interact-ability
comes in it should be
intractable to find the triplet of an
image of the function as well as the two
pre-images associated to this image
given as input a description of this
function
and lastly the trapdoor refers to the
existence of some sort of secret
information t the trap door which if you
have this trapdoor then there is an
efficient way to invert the function
so
there's some algorithm that given the
trapdoor and an image of the function it
can recover the two pre-images in
polynomial time so uh just a bit
pictorially
as i said you have this function which
should be efficient to evaluate so
you're mapping from some input to some
output and this should be done in
polynomial time
and for every input there's also a
sibling so there are always two
pre-images to any given evaluation of
the function
and
the claw free property says that given
this function it should be intractable
to find any such triangle so a triplet
of two pre images and the image
associated to them
and of course there are many such pairs
and in general the image of the function
will be smaller than this output domain
because it's a two to one function
okay so um having this notion of this
tcf this trapdoor clawfree function uh
let's see how one would design a
protocol that leverages this to test for
quantumness
so in the setup phase of the protocol
the verifier will generate this trapdoor
clawfree function
together with the trapdoor it will send
the description of the function to the
approver but it keeps the trapdoor to
herself
so then what it's going to ask the
prover is to give back an evaluation of
this function so the commitment if you
like of the prover is that it evaluated
the function and returned a particular
evaluation of it
and now the the the challenge that the
verifier is going to issue is actually
one of two possible challenges which she
picks with equal probability so with
probability one-half
so one challenge is to request the
pre-image of this image that was
previously reported so just an x such
that f of x is equal to y and of course
the verifier can check this efficiently
by evaluating the function
or the other test is a so-called
equation so an equation is a string d
such that the inner product of d
with the xor of the two pre-images for
this y is equal to zero
so it's some sort of string that has a
special relationship to the two
pre-images
and intuitively this kind of hints at
that claw free property that we think is
that we assume is intractable
but i'll talk more about that in a
second
um so this is the protocol so the the
verifier will
issue one of these two challenges upon
receiving the image
and
as i said in the pre-image test you can
just evaluate the x it receives to check
if it's a valid pre-image in the
equation test she needs to use the track
door to compute the two pre-images for
this y and then evaluate this equation
with the reported d from the verify
and if
either of these two tests is passed then
or i should say if both of these tests
are passed then we say that the prover
has succeeded in this protocol and
otherwise the verifier will reject
so let's see now why a quantum improver
can succeed in this protocol and i think
this will also give you some intuition
about
how this equation test is because i
think that's the more counter-intuitive
bit of the protocol
so on a quantum computer what we would
do is we would initialize two registers
one in which we store the inputs of the
function and one in which we store the
outputs
and what we want is to evaluate the
function in superposition so first we
create a superposition over all inputs
then we evaluate the function coherently
on that superposition
and then to obtain the evaluation of the
function we just measure the image
register
and if you're familiar with simon's
algorithm it's very similar there where
the pre-image register is going to
collapse to a superposition of the two
pre-images compatible with this y and
then this y is sent to the verifier
so then the verifier can request a
pre-image in which case the prover would
just measure this pre-image register in
the computational basis and get back one
of the two pre-images
and in the other case we can see that
what the prover would have to do is
first apply a hadamard operation to this
register and then measure in the
computational basis and again just like
in simon's algorithm
it's not difficult to show that such a
measurement of this state will yield a
string d
that in binary inner product with the
xor of these two pre-images is equal to
zero
so in this way we have a quantum
strategy that can always succeed in this
protocol
so what about um classical strategies
how do we know that there isn't an
efficient classical strategy for such a
protocol
so let's try to sketch an argument for
why it shouldn't be possible for a
polynomial time classical prover to
succeed
so
in this case the prover we assume is
classical and we assume that it can
answer the challenges correctly
and so if we were to run the protocol so
let's say we run the protocol with this
classical prover and perform the
pre-image test we get back a valid
pre-image because we assume the prover
can always succeed
but now
because this prover is classical
all of its operations consist of some
deterministic set of gates that are
applied to a set of input bits
and these bits can also contain
randomness so the prover can also pick
some random bits
as part of its
input on which it evaluates the circuit
but
nevertheless if we fix this randomness
whatever it used in the protocol we can
then just rewind we can uncompute what
the prover did to just
after the point where it reported the
image of the function and then we can
run the other challenge with this prover
so the equation challenge
and by our assumption we know that the
prover must succeed in both of these
and so this means that with this
rewinding operation
we can essentially construct a
polynomial time algorithm that produces
an image of the function of pre-image as
well as a valid equation in both of
those pre-images
so now you might ask um so does this
contradict the ability to find clause or
pre-images for this trapped or claw-free
function
and in fact
it's it's not clear that it does
um because the claw free property says
that it's hard to find both pre-images
together with the image whereas here
we're finding uh the image a pre-image
and some sort of bit of the other
pre-image which we could obtain
from the string d and the other
pre-image that we have
so the tcf's that i've defined so far
are actually not strong enough to
guarantee that
it's hard to also find a valid equation
and this motivates us to introduce a
stronger notion of tcf
which i'll just call strong tcf
and this is essentially the same tcf as
before except we change the claw free
property to this adaptive hardcore bit
property
and this just says that instead of it
being hard to find an image and the two
pre-images it should be hard to find an
image one of the two pre-images as well
as the string d that satisfies an
equation in both pre images so it's kind
of like saying if you have one of the
pre-images then you shouldn't know even
a single bit of the other pre-image so
it's a much stronger property than the
the
claw-free property of regular tcfs
so if we were to use these strong tcfs
in the protocol instead of tcfs then
everything would work so the previously
mentioned classical hardness argument
would work it would give us a
contradiction with this adaptive
hardcore bit property so as long as we
can construct these functions from
standard cryptographic assumptions
um then we have that there's no
efficient classical strategy that can
succeed in this protocol unless you
break that cryptographic assumption on
which these functions are based
so in fact
an even stronger
fact is true about these about the
classical hardness of these protocols
namely if you denote the success
probabilities in these two tests as p
sub pre and p sub eq for pre image and
equation test respectively
what you can show using a slightly
modified variant of the rewinding
argument is that for classical provers
this this inequality needs to be
satisfied in the two probabilities
um so not only can a classical prover
not succeed perfectly but it can't even
um achieve
success probabilities that would violate
this inequality
whereas quantumly we know that you can
succeed perfectly in both tests so this
value is equal to three so there's this
gap between the best classical strategy
and the best quantum strategy
and this means that if we were to
perform this protocol as long as we're
with statistical significance above this
two value which is the classical
threshold
um then we can be confident that we have
quantum advantage um
as long as you know the the
cryptographic assumption was not broken
in the protocol
okay so
this explains how we can design these
proofs of quantumness based on these
strong trapped or claw free functions
um but of course it begs the question
can we do it with just trapdoor claw
free function so without this adaptive
hardcore bit condition
so in answering that we first need to
understand what the adaptive stands for
an adaptive hardcore bit um so it's it
it refers to the fact that the prover
can choose the string d that satisfies
this equation
um so
the prover in some sense has a lot of
leeway here um in that it's free to
choose any such d that satisfies an
equation in the two pre images
rather than say maybe this d being fixed
in advance or being chosen randomly or
something like that
so um to kind of get around this
obstacle and get a protocol that works
even with tcfs
um it was shown in this recent work by
uh greg meyer uh sun wan choi um
that what what you can do is you can
have the verifier try to force a
specific equation onto the prover in
some sense
uh and i hope this will become clear in
in the next slide and this leads to
what's called a computational bell test
protocol
so what is this protocol so now recall
that we have this tcf not we don't have
this
the adaptive hardcore bit property
um
so the protocol is actually um almost
the same as the previous one so we still
start by sending the function we get
back an evaluation of the function
and there's still going to be a
pre-image test which is the same as in
the previous protocol
but now instead of having the regular
equation test
we're going to do something a bit
different so if we're at this point in
the protocol where the approver the
honest prover has reported the image
then it should have this superposition
state of the two pre-images
and what's going to happen now is the
verifier is going to pick a random
string of the same length as these two
pre-images and send it to the prover
and the prover is instructed to create
this state so
to take the string r and compute
coherently the inner product of r with
the two pre-images that are in
superposition here and then put that
result in in a new register so in a new
qubit
so then what what the verifier will do
is she will ask again for
a string d just like in the equation
test of the previous protocol
and this is obtained by doing a hadamard
measurement on this um
second register that holds the pre-image
and measuring it so exactly like in the
previous protocol
and oops and what we can see now is that
the state of this first qubit if you
were to do this measurement
um becomes this one so
um you have a superposition of these two
components that relate to this r string
and the phase is given by this d string
that comes from hadamard measuring the
second register
so what's interesting about this qubit
is that um
it's a bb-84 state so it's either zero
one plus or minus
because when this r inner product with
x0 is equal to r inner product x1
then you just have a zero or a one state
so a computational basis state and if
they're different then you have a
superposition state where the relative
phase is given by the d string that was
reported by the prover
so um
the the idea now is that this you you
can think of the state before the
measurement as a sort of entangled state
like a maximally entangled state between
these two registers and that this d the
d string was the result of measuring
half of this entangled state and now the
verifier will instruct the prover to
measure this other qubit that we're left
with in the same of the two bases that
you would encounter in a normal bell
test so these two um rotated bases
and
um once approver performs this
measurement and sends back the outcome
the verifier can use all of the
information that it has so you can use
the trapdoor as well as the string r and
d to figure out what this qubit was that
the prover uh was supposed to have at
this point in the protocol and from that
she can also determine what the most
likely outcome with respect to this
measurement would be because the outcome
will be biased towards one of the two
elements that you have in your basis
and it's not too difficult to see that
just like in the regular bell test
quantumly you would succeed with
probability 85
so your bias is kind of 85 towards the
most likely outcome
so what is achieved in in this setup is
that a quantum improver can succeed in
this modified equation test with 85
probability whereas classically you
would have just like in the standard
bell test three-quarters probability of
succeeding
so the same kind of gap between quantum
and classical will arise here so again
if we denote the two probabilities for
the two types of tests we find that the
classical threshold here is given by
this inequality and this is again just
like in in the standard bell test it's
because classically you can think of
this as being at most three quarters
whereas in the pre-image test you might
succeed with probability one and so this
gives you a maximum value of four
um whereas quantumly we saw that you
could succeed with um 4.41 violation of
this uh of this linear constraint on the
probabilities
so again this gives us a way to test for
quantum advantage
okay so um
what what diway is going to tell you
about is how we actually implemented
both of these protocols
and before getting to that i need to
just mention how we actually constructed
the two types of functions that we would
use in the protocol so first
the strong trapdoor clawfree function
which is constructed based on the
learning with errors problem
and then for the second protocol this
bell test protocol
the
traptor claw free function because it
doesn't have this strong adaptive
hardcore bit property we actually know
how to construct them from multiple
assumptions
and for our purposes we used factoring
as the underlying hardness assumption so
the hardness of being able to factor
so i'll assume people are familiar with
factoring so i'll just quickly mention
what learning with errors is in case
that is unfamiliar
um so learning with errors is basically
the problem of solving an approximate
system of linear equations over some
finite rings so say over modulo q
so you're given a matrix a and some
vector which is really close to
something of the form a times s so it's
not exactly a times s if it was a times
s you would be asked to just solve
a linear system of equations
um but instead of being given that
you're given a noisy version of the
state plus s so you have some sort of
error vector as it's called that is
applied to this a s and this vector has
very small norms so all of its
components are very tiny and so what you
know is that there's some approximate
linear equation that is satisfied and
the goal is to find the secret vector s
so to solve this approximate linear
equation system
so in the example i have here the the
secret vector is just one zero um
because you know one just selects the
first column which is two zero one one
and that is um the one that is say
closest to this uh result of three zero
one one that we have and the reason i
picked this specific example is because
this was one of the instances of stcf
that we constructed and actually
performed
with the ion trap quantum computer
okay so
that that was the the hardness
assumption that underlies it but how do
we actually construct the functions
so
one type of strong trapped or clawfree
function that you can construct from lwe
is the following
so it takes two inputs a bit b so it's
either zero or one or a vector x which
is um of n components modulo q and what
it does is it just multiplies a with x
uh so you're given this lwe instance
you're given the matrix a and some sort
of vector a s plus e and what you do is
you compute a times x and then condition
on the value of b you then add this lwe
vector um or not so if b is zero you
don't add it if b is one you do add it
and then you
perform what's called a rounding
operation on the result so this rounding
operation just means um taking the most
significant log p components of your
result so if p is equal to uh if p is
equal to two it just means taking the
most significant bit of your result so
from each uh component in this output
vector that you have here you just take
the most significant bit of of each
component and that's that's the result
of your function
and um i won't go into the like why this
satisfies all the properties of a strong
trapped or clawfree function but just to
say like where the clause of this
function r
so they're going to be at the points
zero x and one x minus s
um and it kind of follows from the fact
that um zero x is just the rounded
version of ax and one x minus s is the
rounded version of ax plus e but if this
e is very small as we assumed it is
then this just rounds to the same thing
as ax because the high order bits of the
output are unlikely to be affected by
this small vector e
so that's how we get the clause and you
can see how finding clause for this
relates to finding the secret s
and of course this adaptive hardcore bit
property which is the the one we really
care about here is also satisfied but
that is not at all obvious from
from this description
okay so
that was the stcf now for the
tcf
so here there are many ways in which we
can construct it but the one that was
used here is the so-called robin's
function which is based on factoring so
here you take some composite integer n
which is the product of two large primes
and your function is just x squared mod
n
um so here again let me just i won't go
into why this is a tcf but intuitively
the clause are at the points where if
you get some output y
then x0 and x1 form a claw if x0 squared
is
congruent to y modulo p and x1 squared
is congruent to q modulo p
and so if you know the factorization of
this n then you also know where the
clause are so this is kind of the the
trapdoor aspect of the function as well
okay so we have these functions so let's
see how we would implement the quantum
strategy that we actually ran on the
quantum computer
so the goal is to create this
superposition over evaluations of the
function as i mentioned before
and we can see that
if we were to break this down in terms
of qubits this b is one qubit x because
has n components and they're all modulo
q has n log q qubits
and then this f so you can see that the
output of this function is an m
component vector and we're doing this
rounding operation so you have m log q
bits in your output and then this leads
to that same number of qubits
and in fact for the implementation we
will need an extra register of log q q
bits to do some um to essentially do the
computations required to evaluate this
function
so the parameters we used when
considering instances of this problem to
design these functions were four by two
matrices that were modulo four so q was
four and p is equal to two which means
we were rounding to the most significant
bit and you'll see the specific
instances in in die waste part of the
talk
so at a high level the circuit looks
something like this so
you start by putting all of your qubits
into superposition
and then what you're going to do is
compute inner products between each row
of the matrix and your input vector x as
well as adding
this components of this other vector and
you're going to do all of that in phase
so these
v unitaries just consist of two qubit
phase rotation
so then you need to extract the result
in the computational basis because you
need to report an image to the verifier
so you need to do a an inverse qft which
is only on log q q bits because that's
the the size of the output here you take
the most significant bit so that's the
rounding operation and then
unfortunately you need to uncompute
because we want to reuse this register
for the next component so this
diagram here is repeated for each of the
rows in the matrix a and so you can see
ben that the overall gate count will be
dominated by the size of this matrix a
so it's something like m and log q
and in our case using
various optimizations that
maybe we could talk about later if there
are questions
um we were able to bring this gate count
to under 150 gates
and we really benefited from the
all-to-all connectivity of the ion trap
in order to do this so the ability to be
able to do long range gates between any
of these two qubits
so as i said there were several
optimizations that went into this but
maybe i could talk about that if there
are questions
so then moving on to the other function
the x squared mod n1
so here it will be useful to denote as
little and the
size and binary of this modulus n
so again we want to create an equal
superposition of evaluations of the
function and in this case the number of
qubits that we will need will be 2n plus
1. so it's 2n because you can see that
each one of these registers would
normally have n qubits and the plus 1 is
for that extra qubit that we use in the
computational belt test so the one that
is measured in that rotated basis
so here the the only parameter you can
vary is the size of this n the number to
be uh
the number on which um you know we base
the hardness on being on on the
factoring of this number
and the instances we chose were 8 15 16
and 21. now you might be a bit puzzled
about 8 and 16 because they're not
products of two primes
but again there there are various
tricks that you can do to get around
this so that you can make these cases
work as well
and again i can maybe talk about that if
there are questions
um andrew could you um i think they are
slightly at the edge of the time so if
you can
all right a couple of minutes or so yes
sure sorry i'm almost done anyway
so the circuit structure is is kind of
similar to the other case you evaluate
the function in superposition in phase
and then you do a qft to
convert it to the computational basis
and then you know you have the parts for
doing this computational belt test that
i measured
um so the gate count here is is cubic
but again with various optimizations
it's under 150 gates
and there are various tradeoffs between
qubit number and gate count that you can
achieve and just one point that i'd like
to mention here is that um
even though we're relying on the
hardness of factoring here this protocol
or at least this circuit is much simpler
to implement and it's a much smaller
circuit than say performing shor's
algorithm so there's no phase estimation
being done here or anything of the sort
okay so to to kind of wrap up um
we we have these protocols that are
based on standard cryptographic
assumptions
and as we saw the the number of rounds
of interaction kind of depends on
whether you use the strong trapped
trapdoor clawfree function or the
regular one so you have two rounds of
interaction versus three in the two
cases
um and we also saw like what what the
circuits looked like and we really
benefited from the all tool connectivity
in order to fit everything within the
qubit and gate budget that we had
available to doing this
and one nice thing about the stcf based
protocol is that you could also use it
to generate certifiable randomness so
that's like a very nice um
spin-off application that comes as a
result of this so you know in the future
we'd obviously like to be able to
improve on these constructions so come
up with more efficient constructions uh
maybe have more noise robustness and uh
reduce
um
whatever
like the the number of interactions or
the gate count and so on to make them
more feasible for near-term devices um
so with that i'll now
let dyway tell you about the actual
experiment that was performed
so maybe i'll stop sharing my slides
yeah and sorry for overrunning
thanks thanks andrew um
while division sets up is there any is
there a question that um
so andrew
just to get an idea so what's the size
of uh
more or less you know in the two cases m
and n
that you need to set uh for having a
classically hard instance
um
right so so i should have said that you
know these are proofs of quantum sorry
proofs of principle demonstrations
because of course the instances are so
small that you can solve them
classically efficiently
so probably m n would be on the order of
thousands or hundreds something like
that
um is there a big difference in the two
you know the two different
tests for how many qubits you need at
scale
um
so
i i think they might be quite comparable
so it's a bit hard to compare because in
in the factoring case
there are sub-exponential classical
algorithms for factoring whereas in the
lwe case the best algorithms take
exponential time
and so the
the scaling will be different in the two
cases so you might need a very large n
say
in the factoring case whereas the lwe
instance might be comparatively smaller
um but i think that to to demonstrate
quantum advantage in both cases you
would probably need thousands of qubits
to do it
like maybe 2000 or
2000 was the estimate we had for for
quantum advantage 2000 qubits
okay thanks um
diabetes are you
yeah um so can everyone
yeah yes the screen sharing is working
so
yeah okay
okay
uh so
thanks andrew for the excellent theory
introduction i will now continue
presenting the experiment part of our
work
what you are looking at here
is a high optical access track version
2.0 developed by the sandia national lab
it is essentially the heart of our ion
trap quantum computer
so i will first cover the hardware or
the construction of our computer and
then continue on to how we actually use
it to implement the experiment the
protocols
so our qubits are made of a chain of
eterbian 171 ion trapped with this kind
of surface trap
this type of surface trap particularly
have many micro fabricated electrodes
along this region
that can each be independently adjusted
so this provides us with very
great control over the configuration of
the ion chain we can determine strictly
load desired number of ions as you see
here
and also perform split merge and shuttle
of the ion chain
this capability is crucial to the
implementation of the interactive
protocols we're going to talk about here
so let's further
zoom into the internal state of the each
ion
so each eterbium 171 ion
provide us one physical qubit
in the form of a pair of states in the
high performance split as ground level
this split is insensitive to magnetic
field to the first order which gave our
qubits pretty long coherence time
this plot on the right shows the
measured coherence time t2 of different
qubits in the configuration we used for
the experiment
it goes to around four seconds
another way to put it is in theory this
four seconds
enable us to do about twenty thousand q
qubit gates
but this
is only this t2 is only limited by
technical noise and experimental impact
imperfection in our
case with some careful engineering eq of
larger than one hour has been
demonstrated experimentally by kiwan
kim's group at qinghua university
so the pair of states in the
high-performance splitting are defined
as computation of zero
and computational one
we use state dependent fluorescence to
distinguish them to be more specific we
illuminate this 370 nanometer light onto
the ion and only the computational one
state would resonate with this 370 light
and
scatter photon so
uh
in another word we basically look at if
the ions shine you determine it's zero
or one and to realize individual readout
we use a fiber array to guide the
photons we collected from each
individual ions into a pmt array
to
do individual readout
so we use a high power 355 post laser
you drive what's known as ram on
transition
between the two computational zero and
the computational one state
the control in the phase and amplitude
of the driving laser provide us with
other degrees of readings that we would
need to realize arbitrary single qubit
rotation
to complete the universal gate set
we use
icing gate
here is the icing gate which is mediated
by the collective motion of ions
so because of the coulomb interaction
among other ions
they oscillate collectively
forming different emotional modes as
shown here
by matching the due tune by matching the
detuning of our laser through this
frequencies
of motional modes we couple the internal
state the qubit state
to this motion mode
so this shared emotional modes can thus
be used as quantum bus immediate qubit
gates
so this grants us rtr connectivity which
turns out to be very convenient for this
protocol this type of algorithm which
means each qubit is shown here
can directly couples to any other qubits
within the chain via the shared motion
of us
so putting all the ingredients
introduced above together we can build a
quantum computer
here is some key specs of the quantum
computer we used for this project
for the specific configuration we used
it supports up to 13 qubits
and the two cubic gates finality is
around 99
depending on a specific pair
the single qubit gauge fidelity goes to
beyond three nine
okay so before we dive into the
experimental result and some experiment
implementation let's just review the
protocol one more time
both protocol
starts by prover
preparing a superposition
according to the configuration specified
by the verifier
the prover
then perform a measurement
on the output register and report the
result
which is the image to the verifier
the verifier then requests either a
pre-image test or a equation test as
andrew introduced before so in the case
of lwe-based protocol the equation test
basically means measuring the hard core
bit
in the case of the factoring based
protocol
uh the equation test involves performing
the computational bar test thus we would
require some extra rounds of interaction
based on the provers of response based
on the provers response and the
information obtained using the trap door
the verifier can then decide to weather
pass or fail each single rung of the
protocol
so these other configurations are the
instances of each protocol we used for
the experiment
this table shows the four instances we
used for the lwe-based
trapdoor function
and for the factoring based protocol
as andrew mentioned before we also
studied the four case with n equals 8 15
16 q21
to implement the protocol we use this
two type of circuit
in both case it involves using a unitary
to prepare the superposition
and then perform mid-circuit measurement
as circled in red here
you generate a claw which is a
superposition between x0 and x1
for the lwe based protocol
it ends with measurement performed in
the requested basis
for the factoring based protocol this
actual run of gate plus partial
measurement again in circuit in red are
implemented to do the effective bail
test so the partial measurement is
necessary here
very crucial for the cryptographic
soundness of the interactive protocol
uh it is also in general a crucial
component of quantum
computation it is not only necessary for
quantum error correction but would also
enable other many different type of
algorithms
but it's also very hard to implement
so
one aspect of the challenge
is shown here so we normally pack the
ion chain pretty tightly together
so we can improve so we can perform the
two qubit gates fast and accurately but
such configuration is inconvenient
through partial management because
during partial detection the stray light
easily scatter into qubits
that we want to keep for the rest of the
operation and thus cause the coherence
so to achieve partial measurement
we fully utilize the voltage tunability
granted by our surface trap to adopt the
split and the shutter attack technique
as also used by honeywell and the nist
as shown here in the figure
we perform the gate in a packed chain
but when we want to perform partial
measurements
we split
the chain
we split the subset to be measured apart
from the subset that we want to
we want to keep for the rest of the
protocol
and we shatter the subset we want to
keep away from the detection system to
minimize the impact of straight lines
this video shows the change of the ion
chain configuration throughout a split
and shutter operation
so this is the split and shutter
sequence in particular for the lwe based
protocol the red dashed line
indicates the alignment of the ion to
the center of the system where quantum
operation and detection happens we first
generate this through position
with the whole chain and then split the
chain into two parts so we can measure
the output register
w to get the image but keep the rest of
the chain intact and store them for the
rest of the protocol and then depend on
the requested measurements depending on
the request the test by the verifier we
perform the operation we move the
subset that we kept away back to the
center of the system and perform the
rest of the operation
for the factoring based protocol the
procedure is similar except for an extra
round except the extra round of splits
and the partial measurement is needed to
compete to complete the computation of l
test
so experimentally how do we characterize
the quality of the partial measurement
or you say how do we
how do we probe the coherence of the
qubit throughout the partial detection
because that's our number one concern
regarding the straight line regarding
the computers so the tool we use is
known as is classically known as a is
very classic known as a ramsey
experiment
the relevancy experiment basically probe
the coherence of a qubit
by scanning the relative phase between
two high half paws
the projection of the result of the
composite
rotation in the z direction
depends on the relative phase
and the amplitude of such oscillation
directly relates to the coherence
so in this experiment
we detect we basically do a ramsey
experiment but we insert partial
detection in between the two pi half
plus
so we can see how much the coherence is
disturbed by the partial detection or to
say how much coherence we keep we can
maintain through the partial detection
so as you can see from here
we detected
the we detected the qubits marked in
blue
and the coherence is eliminated because
of the project detection
but
for those qubits we
hit we kept away from the detection
which are marked in orange
the coherence is well maintained
another issue for the shuttling and
project detection
is the face extra phase induced by
shuttling so when the ions are shuttled
around they go through slightly
different magnetic field and thus
accumulates various extra phases
as you can see here
compare with no shuttling
the ramsey fringes of some qubits with
shuttling offset from the others because
of this accumulated phase through
shuttling
so we to perform the protocol or to
correctly perform this partial
measurement we characterize this phase
using this rams experiment
and compensate for that by performing
extra z rotation
on such qubits after every speed and
shutter operation
okay
so here's a result
we perform the experiment both with
actual interaction
or delayed measurements so by delayed
measurement we mean is that all the
measurements are deferred to the end to
pretend they're interactively measured
but actually not so doing this
pairing these two actually enable us to
estimate the arrow overhead of partial
measurement
like a bell test as andrew emphasized
before
each classical proverb can pass the
verifiers challenge with non-trivial
probability
but this probability can be bounded by
an asymptotic plastic threshold defined
on pa and the pb
andrew you used p pre-image and the p
equation test
but here just two depend on the two
tests depend on the verifier's
and
this asymptotic bound
threshold is ultimately what we use to
evaluate the performance of our
experiment
or equivalently whether a verifier would
accept the quantities of the prover is
based on whether they exceed this
threshold in this region classic or in
this region quantum
for the le based protocol
the asymptotic bound is a plus 2 b q p b
no greater than q
for the factoring based protocol such
bound is p a plus 4 pb no greater than
4.
for each configuration and each branch
of choices that the verifier could make
we repeat the experiment the protocol
for two thousand times to collect the
statistics
for all the instances of the lwe
protocol as you can see from here
the quantum improver exceeded the
asymptotic bond
for the factoring based protocol
except for the n equals 21 case
which by far requires the most number of
qubit gates all the other instances past
the threshold
another way to look at the data is the
relative performance shown here
even for each branch of choice the
verifier would make in each instances
so
this is a definition of the relative
performance
it basically shows the percentage
advantage of our experiment
head has against random guests in each
of the case
so a completely noisy quantum computer
will have zero zero advantage over
random guess but the ideal quantum
computer will reach one
comparing the interactive implementation
against the delayed measurement
we can see that some of the branches
are in we can see that the different
branches are impacted by the partial
measurement induced incoherence
differently in particular for this
thickened branch and also they're
squared with a red
square they are robust against such
noise as you see compared with this case
the measurement the inter the
intermediate measurement doesn't really
cost much loss
theoretically we know this is because
such branches do not depend on the phase
coherence between x0 and x1
and because the partial measurement
implemented in our
the way we do in our experiment
dominantly induce face arrow
so those branches
naturally are going to yield a similar
performance interactive or not
for the factoring based protocol another
very interesting observation can be made
you can see from here as my cursor the
pointer is pointing to
is that you can see that the actual
arrow from partial detection actually
increased the performance of one this
particular branch
this is because we are effectively
performing a bell test and you know in a
bell test systematic arrow can boost up
the performance of certain branches of
course at a larger cost to other
branches so though the partial
measurement induced arrow improved this
particular branch it actually comes with
a larger cost to the performance of
other branches and ultimately drop the
performance if we use the asymptotic
bond to evaluate as you see in the
previous slide
so in summary we made a proof of
principle demonstration of interactive
protocol for content advantage
such demonstration at scale about which
require about two thousand qubits by
estimation can conclusively demonstrate
the quantity advantage
such protocol can also be used between
geographically part between
geographically
separated parties to serve as a loophole
free remote benchmark of mountain cloud
service
the protocol can also be used for
certifiable random number generation and
remote state preparation
and
experimentally impo
you see that the mid-circuit measurement
capability demonstrated here is also
crucial for other
important applications like quantum
error correction
and with that i would like to conclude
my presentation and again thanks for the
friend and collaborators that
are contributing to this great work
thanks everyone
thanks a lot davey that's a really
impressive experiment i should i should
add that dairy was
the principal architect of this
experiment so
yeah thanks very much
um
are there any are there any quick
questions before we move to the panel
i guess at this point you can have
questions for
both uh either daivu or andrew
but there's a question in the q a which
says how do you did you come up with a
2000 cubic figure
right maybe i could answer that um
so what we so there there's this website
called lwe challenge
and there they have a list of
the
um some of these very large instances of
lwe that were solved and also the ones
that are unsolved so what we did was we
took the smallest instance that was
unsolved and we just plugged in the
parameters into that uh qubit count that
i showed for the lwe case so like
the matrix dimensions the field size etc
and you could do a similar thing for for
factoring i guess for factoring it's
it's even easier to estimate because
um
there are these industry standards for
uh say rsa in how long the key should be
um in how long sorry the public key
should be
and there you would need maybe like 2048
bits for instance or something along
those lines
so i hope that answers the question
[Music]
so if
there are no more questions uh dave if
you if you stop sharing then maybe we
can pin up the
videos of the panelists
okay so um
so let me just start uh
in introducing the panelists as as there
are
as the videos are highlighted so um
so it's a great panel today so we have
chris monroe who